we regret to inform you that skyscraper
has collapsed pitched as diehard meets a
towering inferno the Dwayne Johnson that
action movie premiered to a
significantly lower than expected
financial reception coming out of its
first weekend in third place at the box
office as a result the would-be
franchise starter will be lucky to make
its money back
much less spark a new series more likely
than not you can forget about a sequel
already so why is this disaster movie
proving to be such a disastrous movie
could the rock star be fading is a movie
actually that bad let's tally up the
numbers and figure out the real reason
skyscraper couldn't stand tall at the
box office what's the damage according
to a breakdown by The Hollywood Reporter
skyscraper only managed a domestic total
of twenty five point five million
dollars in its opening weekend the
unexpectedly small take falls below
universals projected opening of thirty
million dollars or more against a budget
of more than one hundred and twenty five
million dollars and the marketing budget
of at least half that those numbers are
a pretty poor showing one which Box
Office Mojo predicts will translate into
a sixty five to seventy five million
dollar domestic total since these
projected earnings wouldn't even cover
half of skyscrapers total cost that
leaves a huge deficit to Britt in the
international market just for the sake
of breaking even but with only forty
point four million dollars coming in
from the movie's global audience on
opening weekend the chances of even that
happening are looking vanishingly small
I think I've seen this if skyscraper
feels too familiar to be all that
interesting that's actually partially by
design prior to the movie's release
Johnson described the movie on his
social media as a film that paid homage
and respect the classic action movies
that inspired me and entire generations
die hard two towering inferno to the
fugitive the thing about those classic
action movies is not that we've seen
them before but that we've already seen
them all get ripped off we've seen
cliffhanger we've seen speed we've seen
daylight and they all feel a lot like
skyscraper so as much as Johnson and the
movies producers would like to praise
skyscraper as a modern classic it's not
a quality that feels or that earned it
doesn't help that skyscraper comes off
as feeling similar to some of Twain
Johnson's other
at movies from San Andreas to rampage -
even the fate of the Furious but that's
not the movies problem that speaks to
issues with the movie's marquee star
overexposed over a 14 month span
starting in April 2017 Dwayne Johnson
has been a lead star in five different
movies including Baywatch Jumanji and
now skyscraper the avalanche of content
shows no signs of stopping but it might
already be bringing in diminishing
returns in short Johnson has opened
himself up to the possibility of serious
overexposure with no less than 10 movies
potentially coming down the pipeline for
the actor you'd have to be crazy not the
thing that were at risk of some serious
rock fatigue if it can happen to Star
Wars it can happen to the people's
champion could skyscrapers failure
inspire Johnson to tone down the
full-court press maybe after all how is
the country ever go into a lectin
president if everyone's burned out on
his movies the competition whatever its
own faults may be skyscraper was also
outmatched at the box office by more
critically acclaimed competition on one
side there's Hotel Transylvania 3 summer
vacation another entry in the Adam
Sandler starring animated series about
Dracula and Friends that family-friendly
sequel on the weekend with 45 million
dollars easily trouncing skyscrapers
debut showing in second place there's a
man on the wasp with nearly 29 million
dollars according to both Rotten
Tomatoes scores and cinema scores people
walked out of these two movies feeling
satisfied and ready to spread some
positive word-of-mouth to its detriment
at the box office
skyscraper is proving more divisive and
without good word-of-mouth behind it
things are only going to get worse from
here catch you later
so does skyscraper really deserve this
belly flop of a reception well yes or no
put simply skyscraper is not the kind of
appointment viewing that makes you want
to slip out to the cinema regardless of
how bombastic as special effects might
be instead it's the kind of thing you
see accidentally killing time with an
in-flight movie while you're on a plane
multiple reviews emphasize the movie's
nature as something slight and in
essential enjoyable enough as a nice
diversion but not good for much else in
a crowded movie landscape good enough
often doesn't cut it not when other
movies are competing for the same
audience
these days of razor-thin profit margins
sometimes are so you need to make a box
office bomb
[Music]